when you just need an escape from fear
itself
turn to crafts that's right you can go
from
anxiety hypertension and overthinking to
yarn and googly eyes and popsicle sticks
all week long we've been crafting and
celebrating crocheting and knitting
are so hot right now that hansel he's so
hot right now
in fact even the gen ziers are crafting
they're calling it
hashtag craftcore that's right tiktok is
being flooded with the videos
of their work it's such a cool world and
one of our vffs makes sweaters that gets
millions of views and tons of
love on tiktok please welcome liv
hoffman
andrew gosh
i've got my dictionary and you've got
your crocheted sweater i feel like we
belong together
we do now tell us
about the harry styles sweater that
inspired you well so
i mean i've been a pretty long time fan
of harry and i'm a pretty big fan of jw
anderson the brand so when i saw the
sweater it kind of just sparked
something in me
um and you know it kind of just comes
from a place of not really being able to
afford the original one
um and it was my first like major
crochet project
so i took it on i made a little video i
posted it on tick tock
and it definitely blew up in a way that
i just absolutely never
expected it to it was huge and jw
anderson actually put his pattern out
there such a cool designer because his
sweaters are very expensive
and that was sort of what inspired you
to find the alternative and then he
shared that with everybody which is such
a cool attitude
it made me love him so much more will
you tell us about the sweater you're
wearing right now
well so i kind of just like stumbled
into this like whole crochet community
on tick tock that i didn't even know
existed
and so when the idea came about i just
posted a video on tik tok i gave them
absolutely no requirements they could
send in a square of their choice
um and i opened a p.o box and within
like a couple weeks i had almost 400
squares from
all over the world middle east asia from
europe from all over america
and thus my baby was born
i love it liv a sweater that unites us
all would you be up for a challenge and
make something by the end of the show i
have an idea
so i will take your challenge
thank you liv okay we're gonna check in
with you throughout the show
let's check in with our crochet vff who
we get to craft with all week and or we
get to craft
today liv how's it going you know what
we're making really good progress
i don't want to spoil too much but we're
getting there
well i'm very excited liv i'm so excited
to be doing this show with you i'm such
a huge fan and you've made such a splash
on the scene and
like people love you and i totally get
it and i'm psyched to be hanging with
you today
thank you so much thanks liv brb i live
we're almost out of time but did you
make something
[Applause]
are you the cutest person ever or the
cutest person ever
you think i'm the cutest person ever you
are i'm
so weak it's coming to a close tomorrow
we'll see you then
liv thank you so much thank you to
everyone who came on this
fantastic show today thank you for being
here
everyone maybe we'll get to see you
again
[Music]